Міністр соціальної політики Андрій Рева збурив соцмережі
своїми заявами про звички харчування українців та причини високих витрат на їжу
От коли ми говоримо про те
що німці 14, а ми 50 витрачаємо
знаєте, це тут тоже система пріоритетів
Середньостатистичний німець витрачає на їжу 355 євро
А українець - близько 40 євро
Утім, у відсотковому відношенні до середньої заплатні
українці й справді витрачають на харчування значно більше
По-перше, середня зарплата німців непорівнювано вища
По-друге, продукти харчування в Україні хоч і дешевші, ніж у ФРН
але не настільки, щоб говорити про дешевизну харчів
Навпаки, ціни на їжу в Україні щороку зростають
тоді як у  Німеччині інфляція майже непомітна
Тож порівняння міністра - некоректне
адже не відображає повної картини
До речі, найбільше грошей - в середньому 35%
місячного доходу - німці віддають на оплату житла і комунальних послуг
Німці - вони трошки інакше їдять
У них раціон інший
Поглянемо на раціон німців.
За статистикою, у 2016му німці найбільше їли молочних продуктів
молока, сирів та масла
Так само як і українці
На другому місці в німців - фрукти та овочі
в українців - овочі та хліб
Що ж стосується м'яса й ковбаси
то в середньому німець з'їдає їх щомісяця на чотири кілограми більше, ніж українець
Тобто дієта німців не так уже й відрізняється від раціону українців.
Разом з тим, здебільшого ощадливі німці
не дуже ощадливі в плані закупок харчів
За статистикою, середня німецька родина
щороку викидає на смітник 80 кілограмів продуктів харчування